In the United States, about 100,000 people every year–
have bone breaks so big that they can’t heal properly.
This can lead to severe disability or even death.
A new bone-growing treatment starts by putting
a scaffolding material called collagen
in the site of the break.
The body’s own stem cells migrate in
and attach to the scaffold.
An injection solution is added containing tiny bubbles
and DNA that codes for a protein
to stimulate new bone growth.
Ultrasound, like the kind used in a doctor’s office,
then causes the bubbles to explode,
punching short-lived holes
in the stem cells, allowing the DNA to get inside.
The stem cell reads the DNA and makes the protein,
which stimulates the cell to make new bone
and heal the break.
So far the procedure has only been tested in animals.
But it may soon be tried in people.